i got to say one of my favorite things
about the holidays is that i get to
spend time with our dear old friend
minty the candy cane who briefly fell on
the ground
[Music]
yeah and uh people really enjoy hearing
uh his catchy theme song there's only
one problem we only get to hear minty's
holiday song once a year
but not anymore
now you can hear minty's classic theme
song all year round there's minty's
summer minty song
it's become a simple fact that minty's
covered in seagull crap there's fishing
line stuck to his spine but that's all
fine it's summertime
there's yeah
there's a
there's one for country music fans when
america is free and there's guns for you
and me
the candy cane will lead the tea party
yeah
there's a spoken word version featuring
academy award-winning actor morgan
freeman
oh when the holidays come around
if you listen real close you can hear an
unmistakable sound
why that's our old friend minty the
candy cane who briefly fell on the
ground
gonna get an oscar for that
and finally my favorite a minty remix
for his european fans
the holidays are round
kitty's on the ground we never will get
up and god is dead
[Music]
that was horrible
those are all great but for me nothing
beats the classic minty song it's my
[Applause]
fell on the ground
minty fell on the ground now minty's
covered in ghoul cause minty fell on the
ground for just a moment or two
it's becoming evident he landed in
excrement but never fear cause minty's
here to make christmas excellent minty
fell on the ground now minty's
covered on the ground
[Music]
this is the way he threw those canes at
me he was being generous he was not
being generous
his ass is fired
look at that
is he still back there
have him peek out for just a second hey
minty peek out here for just a second
come on vinci
minty you son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]
you